ce ne soit tout d'abord je voudrais dire
merci à marcory c'est elle qui m'a prié
si je puis dire d'être ne pas que ces
charmantes je suis et je dois dire que
j'ai dit oui sans hésiter sans même
réfléchir
[Applaudissements]
pardonnez le super intendant l'origine
on y est tous les jours je jouais très
belle soir ils sont vraiment très
satisfaite
effectivement de très beaux cadeaux à
savoir que l'élection de miss martinique
se passe avec nos partenaires à miss
martinique partira avec une garde-robe
grâce aux partenaires maquillage merci
la coiffure
merci pour tout ce qu'ils nous apportent
qui nous soutiennent voilà
[Musique]
je prends goût à celle là donc je le
pense que celle de miss france peut
aussi venir se rajouter dans la liste il
n'y en a qui n'ont pour l'instant mais
pourquoi pas deux
[Rires]
c